[Music]
hey everyone welcome to minorities
report the vanguard of people who don't
have Vanguard accounts the weather
report for those whose bodies are
biologically unsuited to the cold we
started at the bottom and now we're here
where the is here
that's we'll find out each week with the
funniest comedians in America bringing
you perspectives you'll find a lot of
other places but also here please
welcome my guess we have sherry Cola who
you might have seen on the show good
trouble hello sherry brown hi and she
will never let you forget it and then we
also have my buddies Eric Griffin from
workaholics I'm dying up here and his
podcast riffin with Griffin Oh
Maz Jobrani from his stand-up special
immigrant available streaming on Netflix
and his back-to-school podcast you don't
like a superior doughnuts bug you just
it's over it's gone it's done why would
you flex affairs cancelled why do you
plug all my canceled shows why would you
why would you even bring that up our
share of clunkers except cherry he was
trying to forget that show write to a
hit so let's jump in president drops new
travel ban President Trump said Monday
he was going to be stopping all
immigration to the United States and
then walked it back to a delay on
issuing new green cards still making
this whole thing about immigration Maas
your people have been banned in the very
beginning how's it going in there yeah I
want to welcome all of you to the travel
ban as an iranian-american
the first week in office he put down the
travel ban if you remember maybe you
know because there's been a million
things that have happened since but the
first week and all those airports there
was protests and they said people from
Iran and six other Muslim countries
couldn't come in and they said there was
a temporary travel ban they were looking
to do it for 90 days till he could
figure out what to do with immigration
well four years later all he's doing is
adding more
treasons I just want to welcome you all
and don't plan on seeing any of your
relatives from China or wherever you're
from Eric what are you Eric Wow yeah you
people always want to know so they can
know how to hate me but speaking of
immigrants that we're trying to keep out
of this country I don't know if you will
like recognize how many immigrants and
percentage of those who are not citizens
of the United States work in medical
care and are considered essential
workers so we have and this is as of
2016 but physicians 30 percent of
physicians are foreign-born dentists
23.7% you have nurses and medical
assistants
you know nursing 23 percent and of that
23 percent eight point seven not even
citizens of the United States so again I
think we're keeping up I mean Filipinos
alone you block them and there goes your
medical care nursing home Filipinos this
is what I don't like this way I don't
like medical shows on TV because there's
not one Filipino nurse on grace not one
medical show with all Filipinos yeah
that's what it is
and it comes on at 8 o'clock 5:30
started Twitter petitions about this the
one that makes the most sense to me is
the dietitians and nutritionists because
I feel like every single thing I hear
from these professionals is some like
foreign myth that my grandma would tell
me like if you want to be skinny just
tape a piece of ginger to your belly
button you know like this you know you
know sherry you wondering I know I know
that the Chinese parents want their kids
to be gotten lawyers doctors engineers
same thing with Iranian parents and and
and you guys Eric thank you for bringing
it up my god I've been doing comedy and
acting for 22 years how many times that
I watch your ers you're grazing that
you're all that stuff and I'm like half
of my Iranian friends and doctors any
hospital you go to in Los Angeles you
got a bunch of Iranians bunch of Indians
all that finally after like 20 years
they got one Indian doctor on Grey's
Anatomy or something as you guys were
saying people don't know and the funny
thing is to like keep them out keep them
out keep them out but listen you are
keeping out doctors and you're keeping
out scientist you keeping out researches
you know who's winning in all this
Canada Europe because that's where all
these people that are the brains of
these countries that used to come to
America are now going they're moving on
the pandemic has revealed a new kind of
person in America essential workers
they're the ones whose jobs are so
important that they have to keep on
doing them even at the risk of dying I
just really I really have a problem with
the word essential you know like using
the word all of a sudden now things that
really mostly rich people don't want to
do they said oh that's essential
essential is a euphemism for expendable
I mean you're paid well in the first
place they weren't paid well you know
they're not looked after and all of a
sentry like hey we need you to come to
my place leave the stuff outside and
then go away just drop it
yeah they're taking it way too seriously
my post mate last night was literally
wearing a cape you know it was it was
food is being delivered by the Watchmen
yes get Marvel on the phone what's
happening I have heroes
I have essential worker guilt so you
know mr. Trevor who smells like weed and
ate half of my onion rings now I have to
tip him triple just cuz I feel so bad
and I'm so thankful you know I would
like to I would like to add the guy at
the liquor store who recommends the
wines as my essential worker that guy
has kept me going
he's got me he knows his wines I give
him the price range and you've done me
well Gerard
whatever spoken like a man with wife and
kids yeah I really do seriously
all the people that are out there for
sure I mean grocery store employees that
are on the frontlines of this and the
people that are not respecting their
space at all and trying to get grabby
it's uh it's it's definitely tough but I
was looking at this list of essential
workers and no one on here is rich
they're everyone that is working in
hardware stores and plumbers contractors
and tradesmen I mean other than the
people that own these companies
landscapers pool care well al that's
something the 1% has been trying to keep
from us all this time we really don't
need them we don't need these
politicians who think they're doing us a
favor by giving us a stimulus package we
gave them the money it's their job now
to keep the economy afloat they are not
essential so I think that they're
realizing that and and they're freaking
out it doesn't feel like it does feel
like this list though was like written
at an Illuminati meeting you know like a
bunch of super rich people sit around a
table and they said ooh what do you guys
not want to do well I don't want to
clean my pool but I'm on the list
pool why don't wanna pump my gas gas
stations gardeners you know everyone
Worman i've been i've been skimming
skinny-dipping every morning so I'm very
grateful for the pool cleaner we all
just took a moment we all just took a
moment it had a visual that's what just
happened it's when Eric said is exactly
where I've been in the same clothes for
a month and haven't showered so no
dipping I smell you from here and I
respect it once again spoken like a man
with a wife and kids so you guys know
this also a disproportionate amount of
black and Latino people are being
affected by this pandemic the pandemic
is affecting everyone but like most
things not equally black and brown
communities have borne the brunt of the
worst
why is that what's going on here well in
my opinion it just it just boils down to
economics you know I saw some of these
numbers like in Wisconsin it says black
people represent 6% of the population
and 40% of the Kovach 19 fatalities some
it just goes to like people you're
talking about what works people's income
do they have health insurance do they
have access to go to hospitals do they
have and this is what this is the
trickle down of why it's important for
people to have access to affordable
health care I'm getting kinda hot and
heavy
listening to you talk statistics I will
say I did experience a little racism in
a public elevator this group of four
middle-aged white men came in and
immediately asked me do you have
coronavirus I ended up telling him to
apologize because I'm a badass but
I guess there's kind of a silver lining
now for Asians you know cuz people are
automatically staying six feet away from
me in public I have a forcefield you
know being Asian it's kind of like the
superpower
yeah racism is actually protecting you
it's know and it's so dumb because when
you look at the numbers the people that
are being affected the least are Asians
you know the numbers show it that like
you know ages aren't getting there that
had the least fatalities in at least
cases because listen I've been I travel
all the time we all are comedians we
travel right who's guys who's had the
Maxon for five years now rockin masks as
long as I can remember
painting for years okay even through all
the racism discrimination we're still
getting an A+ in terms of survival it's
very young Brown those Korean face
shields those visors sun protection yeah
that's the problem also as a Korean
mother-in-law what's that I love he
loves Erik Griffin more than she likes
me I've never seen that woman laugh
harder to joke she can't tell you two
apart that's why I just I just know one
Korean phrase hajima I said yeah Korean
barbeque but anyways I'm sorry to cut it
no no please tell your Korean barbecue
you know it's a shame because I miss can
we have our BQ we're not even gonna be
able to go when's the next time we're
gonna be able to go to like a Monday or
Korean barbecue that was tell it when
you go to Korean barbecue you can't
complain to the chef that the food
doesn't come out right because you cook
it yourself
who doesn't over laughing I go to Korean
barbecue restaurants and afterwards I
give myself three stars on Yelp and got
called somebody else you
chinese
to who my mother-in-law korean first of
all she probably hate dislikes chinese
people's gonna say what she hated the
most about that was being called chinese
that's what she really hated with the
racism it's naughty with the racism from
other people she was like it was an
ongoing feud between me and your
mother-in-law
speaking of moms how was your mom how's
your grandma doing your mom I assume if
she's anything like my Korean
mother-in-law doesn't give a she's
out there my mom wants to come over
every day and kiss me on the cheek I'm
like I need to draw the line cuz I'm so
paranoid like she dropped off food the
other day and I couldn't even look her
in the eye I didn't want us it was too
risky I have sprayed her down with Lysol
from head to toe which was fine because
of course she had you know the full
armor because Asian moms have all of the
equipment they've been training for
years but the generation above them give
no like my grandpa is so horny for
mahjong right now like he just wants to
go play with his friends and my mom has
him on a leash too ruthless they're just
out in the world you know
mouth-breathing next to the produce
section as you say my mom is my mom's a
widow of three and a half years so she
was cool initially I think she was
yelling at guys in the supermarket
she says she said six feet oh so now
he's just begging for any sort of
contact like my parents are
driving me bananas you know for a lot of
reasons you know they just you know they
they always wonder well you got to go to
the stores like no you don't have to go
to the store you know and then my mom
has dementia she's got my it's mild but
it's still you know you know it's
Groundhog Day because every day we got
to explain to her there's a virus and
you can't go outside you know because
the real essential workers that we
didn't talk about earlier are the people
that have to take care of like sick
people mentally ill people people that
those people are out there having to
still go take care of someone who can't
take care of themselves even worse their
real feeling is cuz I know all of us
feel the same way about this what I'm
about to say now I'm staying away from
my parents because I don't want to be
the reason I killed my mom or something
you know it's like I don't you know we
traveled a lot you know even as a comic
we're touching that mic and you know you
dirty-ass comics er spitting on it and
you know if some kind words are doing
like Bobby Lee is putting the
mic in his mouth for a joke and it's
like you know that microphone is a germ
baton like I could send that microphone
into 23 of me yeah man we could find out
yeah go ahead they I read somewhere that
human beasts touch their face about 2500
times a day I don't know how or what but
that's the statistic I read and the last
time I did stand-up was March 12 I was
doing all that and it's funny because as
soon as I started seeing people talking
about like scratching your face and all
this other stuff I felt like I finally I
was like I got an itch in my furrows
like I think I'm sick I think I keep
looking back at all the stuff leading up
to it and I'm thinking from all what you
were saying all my travel is all the
hands shaking the meet and greets the
microphone I go I must have had it
because there was a little tickle there
a couple of days where I was a little
congested you know what you know what
mom I got you know I alright so my girl
she's she's a model alright so she went
to we I took it her we went to Fashion
Week in New York you know and she got
sick you know and and I did I didn't get
sick you know what I mean and and I was
thinking to myself maybe I had it like
two months ago
and gave it to her she got sick and we
got over it but I don't know because now
I feel like how do you like I never got
tested because I've just been home you
know what I mean nobody in fashion you
could ever know everyone's vomiting
anyway yeah what I'm saying though is
that like and I didn't mean to humble
brag about my girl being a model totally
gorgeous but anyway the point is the
point is so getting back to it is just I
and that's why I was so worried about
like I don't want to go near my mom
because if people need to realize this -
it's a horrible death for people over 70
they had to be isolated you can't be in
the room with them and they just waiting
to die or recover and I was like I don't
want to be responsible for that and
that's why I agree with you they even to
go back even further miles about like
yes I understand the corona virus is
different from all these other things
that people die from every year two
million people die every year in the
United States that's the mortality rate
for all different types of things and we
don't want all two million to be the
corona virus you know what I mean so
when is this gonna be over and what's
going to be different it will end
on November 3rd when Joe Biden wins the
election and we find out it was a
democratic hoax Wow and what's going to
be different for me is I've always been
a handshake I think that's part of like
when you do a firm handshake it makes me
feel like you're passionate about your
life but now I ain't shaking nobody's
hand I'm gonna be namaste in the
out of people
namaste away from me I'm uh I'm uh I'm a
hugger
so I know what you mean I'm a hugger I
like to hug people so like that's gone
I'm not doing meet-and-greets that kind
of stuff first what Maz is a hand shaker
eric is a hugger I usually just go
straight for the kiss you know so a lot
is gonna change for me my mouth on the
mouth baby you know me zero to 100 I
think for real with like zero chance of
it ever coming back I think September
2021 that's my true prediction are you
think about when we're on stage we're on
stage I mean
how many times I know I've spit like
into the seventh row you know I mean
just like how many times how many times
have people spit at you Eric I've seen
your act okay professor Maas over here
my prediction is for as date I think we
will be limited release of all people
around June 15 and those who are elderly
65 and older or compromised immune
systems I think they will be asked to
remain inside and hopefully we get back
to business a little bit
non-essential business non-essential
essential you know what I want to say
though just for the record all jokes
aside truly respect and and just so much
love to all of the people at the front
lines you know and essential workers
because we're just shooting the on
our couch right now and they're you know
kind of I mean we are responsible our
industry is responsible for a shitload
of stuff people are watching and making
fun of on Netflix and true yeah and and
and my zoom career is taking off I'm on
your show now I'm a series regular on
six zooms right now thank you so get
canceled just like all the other shows
don't work well you know why did you own
the network we're never getting
cancelled I will probably get kids all
right thank you so much guys
one more time cherry cola Maz Jobrani
Eric Griffin really appreciate you stay
safe thank you very much everybody for
watching this first episode this has
been Minority Report
[Music]
people stop with your zoom shows no
disrespect this was on its way
it just it just goes black it just goes
black right now
[Music]